the US and its ally Turkey are locked in
a growing confrontation over the US
military presence in Syria national
security advisor John Bolton is cutting
short his visit to Turkey after being
snubbed by its leader president Erdogan
is angry over the slowdown of US troop
of the EU's US troop pullout from Syria
he said altering the withdrawal is a
serious mistake Holly Williams is in
Istanbul Holly good morning good morning
there's now confusion about when exactly
the roughly 2000 US troops in Syria are
going to leave that's unsettling for
some of America's partners here in the
Middle East and it has infuriated
Turkey's president Reggio you've heard
one to remind you of the background here
president Trump abruptly announced last
month that the US would pull its troops
out of Syria saying Isis had been
defeated there that assertion was widely
contradicted and the announcement
apparently led in part to the
resignation of defense secretary James
mattis but on Sunday national security
adviser John Bolton seemed to roll back
president Trump's withdrawal plan on a
visit to Israel Bolton said that US
troops would remain in Syria until Isis
is defeated and until neighboring Turkey
guarantees it will not attack America's
Kurdish partners on the ground
Turkey's been critical of US involvement
in Syria because it says America's
Kurdish allies are a terrorist
organization and that's why Turkey
another key US ally is now angry and
says it will not make any concessions
biana yeah one regional expert called
air diwan's comments a big put down to
the United States Holly Williams in
Turkey thank you for your reporting